las vegas weekly is making sure you can
get out and explore
safely the magazine has put together an
incredible road trip issue
with drives that are five hours or less
so take a look now about one hour away
we've got hot spots
mount charleston lake mead and valley of
fire
a unique pick they're highlighting as
well nelson nevada
that's an old mining ghost town we'll
hear more about that
all right two hours away there's
extraterrestrial highway
lake havasu city and if the views are
what you're after
grand canyon west in three hours drive
you can get to death valley national
park
and bryce canyon which has got so many
interesting rock formations
four hours from here folks take a look
check out glen canyon national
recreation area
and snap a selfie at horseshoe bent
let's check in now with the lady in
charge cindy moon reed who put this
entire list together
cindy you've done so much research
visited many of these yourself
what are your favorites oh my gosh
there's
so many uh actually during covid
i did check out grand canyon west and i
got to try
um try to to face my fear of heights by
going on the sky bridge
and uh and staring down at the grand
canyon from
above and i'm proud to say that i
actually
did it and i'm very proud of myself
you faced your fears well done cindy and
many folks still have to do that i still
have to get out there and check that out
too
and have you been to bryce canyon
yourself uh we have friends who went
went there last year and they took the
most beautiful pictures
yes i did i went with my mom a few years
ago so
zion national park gets most of the
attention
but rice canyon is truly an incredible
place to visit they have these like
weird spire tower like rock formations
called
hoodoos and um it really is like a
fantastic sci-fi alien landscape and
it's easy to visit from las vegas
yeah it really is so in the age of coven
cindy traveling looks a little different
for everyone now you've compiled a
helpful list of to-do's to make sure we
are prepared for that road trip can you
highlight just a few of those important
things for us
um well i would say speaking of bryce
canyon
when i was there hiking i saw this girl
trying to
hike down basically the side of a cliff
wearing strappy high-heeled
sandals and she was like one strap
fail away from falling off the cliff and
so i think the number one thing is to
make sure you have
the appropriate footwear if you're going
outdoors
just safety first and and also like you
might
be going outside of where there is cell
reception
so uh do a little planning ahead and
actually print out a physical
map uh just like they did in the old
days the 1980s i lost cindy you guys
i apologize um cindy we're having some
audio issues i'm not sure if they're on
my end or your end but i want to thank
you so much for your time
and please check out this week's edition
of las vegas weekly christian